como muchas mujeres esta ciudadana
estadounidense descubrió que está
embarazada tras seis semanas sin embargo
es cuando se suele detectar la actividad
cardíaca embrionaria y fetal y en el
estado de texas tras la aprobación de
una nueva ley cuando se detectan latidos
el aborto se vuelve ilegal pero esto no
iba a cambiar su decisión
tengo 29 años soy propietaria de una
vivienda tengo un trabajo estable mi
carrera ha despegado tengo dos títulos y
si me miras sobre el papel podrías decir
que es una situación ideal para una
persona que se encuentra embarazada pero
al final del día estaba embarazada y no
quería estarlo y no necesitaba ninguna
otra razón además de esa para decir que
voy a buscar un aborto
y le costó dos intentos para lograr
abortar por sí misma gracias a varios
amigos que le consiguieron medicamentos
especiales ella describe esta
experiencia como la más dolorosa de su
vida
fue un reto pero fue un reto que pude
afrontar y que pude manejar sé que hay
muchas más personas en el estado de
texas y a medida que nos acercamos la
decisión de raw muchas más van a
enfrentarse a un reto y no van a poder
superarlo y continuar con un embarazo
que nunca quisieron tener
se espera que a finales de junio la
corte suprema- de mayoría conservadora
se pronuncie sobre el futuro del fallo o
robo contra whale de 1973 la filtración
de un borrador reveló recientemente la
posible intención del máximo tribunal de
derogar la ley que regula el derecho al
aborto a nivel federal lo que desató
protestas en todo el país si se
concretan los temores de muchas los
estados tendrían potestad de imponer sus
propias reglas cuando de aborto se trata
varios estados ya tienen listas de
restricciones al derecho con algunas
normativas incluso más restrictivas que
las de texas
[Aplausos]